hello and welcome to the great energy
transition a new series from
Intelligence Squared in partnership with
Cummins and it's all about bringing
together leading voices to discuss the
really big questions around the
environment energy and the road to Net
Zero my name is Helen chesky I'm hosting
and we've got three topics coming up
we're going to cover one of them today
and that is what's happening between now
and 2030 to achieve Net Zero but in the
two coming uh in the two coming episodes
um discussions will be covering what hap
what needs to happen between 2030 and
2050 and then beyond that the role of
corporations in the energy transition so
we're following it all the way through
and today we're focusing on what's
Happening before 2030. now we all know
that cop27 is just around the corner and
we also know that there's a better world
out there there's a world where we don't
have to burn fossil fuels where we don't
have to generate so much air pollution
in order to meet our basic needs where
things are cheaper and fairer and we're
not destroying our entire planetary
system for just so we can keep in the
long term just so we can keep using
particular Technologies in the short
term it's all out there this better
future but it's not just a possibility
we know now that getting there is an
urgent challenge
um and in order to prevent the worst
climate disasters you know we hear these
statistics all the time Net Zero needs
to be reached by 2050 but if you ask any
climate scientists they'll say the
sooner we make that transition the
better it's all going to be
um and you know Global emissions need to
fall 45 by 2030 and that is a
significant challenge but a lot of the
foundation already exists now it's time
for the hard work of making it happen so
today we're going to be focusing on the
immediate challenge what needs to happen
before 2030 just the next eight years
it's not far ahead so here's how it's
all going to work we'll hear from each
of our expert speakers we have three of
them about their priorities and their
insights as they look ahead to this
gigantic task and the remake taking of
the American and global economy and then
we'll have discussion between ourselves
and after that you get to ask your
questions now you can actually start on
that now there's a you should be able to
see a q a button if you click on that
you can put your question and do include
your name and perhaps where you're from
we'd love to know
um and then we'll read the questions out
at the end in that question section at
the end so you can be asking questions
whenever they occur to you on the way
through so do do start submitting
questions as soon as you're ready to so
let's start off and meet our speakers
we've got Dr Chris Gregg he's the
leading researcher on decarbonisation
and zero Net Zero Energy transitions at
Princeton University he came into
Academia after almost three decades in
industry and his research focus is
identifying and overcoming the
challenges of rapid decarbonization and
um recently and very significantly he
co-led Princeton's influential Net Zero
America study which came out in 2021 and
is currently co-leading similar efforts
in Australia and Asia and then our
second panelist is Lucy you she's the
CEO at octopus energies Center for Net
Zero which is a Research Unit leading
pioneering research to make the Future
Energy System a reality she's got
Decades of experience building Tech
Ventures and developing Tech policy and
also in influencing regulation for the
UK government the European commission
and the UN and last but certainly not
least we have Jonathan wood who is the
vice president of new power engineering
at Cummins which is a fortune 150 Global
power technology company he works to
develop the company's Innovations in its
alternative power business which houses
its electrified power fuel cell and
hydrogen Technologies and he's worked at
Cummins for 27 years most recently as
the vice president for components
engineering so this is our expert panel
we clearly have lots and lots to talk
about but let's get started perhaps with
a little bit of scene setting so it's a
familiar thing Chris but perhaps you
could just lay out what exactly and
briefly if you would what exactly is net
zero and why does it matter
yeah thanks Helen so I think for a long
time we've realized that climate change
was was something that was causing a lot
of problems with the Earth and that we
had to do something and we were setting
our targets like keep below two degrees
C of temperature rise or later 1.5
degrees C and this was really confusing
you know how do you allocate this
temperature Target amongst different
actors whether they be States Nations or
companies or individuals and so the
transition to a kind of a net zero kind
of narrative for me has made it real and
tangible for everybody so whether you're
a company a city a nation you set
yourself a target of Net Zero you know
exactly what you have to do in terms of
your net emissions the next challenge is
what's the right kind of energy mix and
set of technologies that would get you
there so so I think it's really set
ourselves a tangible Target and that's
why I think it's really important
now the Net Zero study at Princeton
which you co-led was was really
influential because it really dug into
the details like you know you've made
the point for the slogan I guess you
know here's an easy target Net Zero go
but then of course you know the devil is
all in the detail and and that was what
this report dug into and you know and uh
it was it was red because people were
like oh well what does this look like
and I was just curious about you know
for you having done all that work what
do you think the most significant or
surprising outcomes of that report were
in terms of what was actually in the
report
yeah I think the the most eye-catching
thing is the sheer speed and scale at
which you have to build assets and
infrastructure we've never seen uh
anything parallel to this in the history
of humankind right so it's just a
massive infrastructure building program
and with that comes a massive Capital
mobilization challenge a massive
Workforce mobilization challenge
and because we are moving to uh
resources which are let's say low
operating cost and relatively free but
they take up a lot of land so you know
it's going to create new and interesting
ways that we're interacting with the
natural environments
um yes we're going to overcome climate
change in time but but there's going to
be a whole new range of challenges with
with the natural environment with
communities and I think this challenge
of putting Capital to work at a rate we
haven't done before
and the sheer amount of supply chain
upheaval
infrastructure development Etc I I think
we're in for a a real roller coaster of
the next three decades and that to me
was the most surprising thing the second
most surprising thing is that we can get
there without Energy Services having to
cost more than they do today as a
percentage of GDP so that was kind of
good news
um but but really the eye-catching thing
was the was the sheer scale and speed at
which we have to move
it is it is a big thing but I think it's
great as you say to see it as an
opportunity you know there's an
opportunity to have something better
rather than just being stuck with this
thing that doesn't work okay so let's
let's meet our other panelists um Lucy I
wanted to come to you next and the scent
you know Center for Net Zero perhaps
that's a phrase you know not quite
familiar for some of our audience could
you explain what it does and how it does
it
yeah of course so uh we're a
not-for-profit Research Unit we're part
of the octopus Energy Group as you can
see behind me
um our research is focused on delivering
the Future Energy System by providing
important evidence and insights to
policy makers to energy and climate
leaders and to city leaders and a lot of
our research is is aimed at developing
and sharing models and tools but
crucially those are models and tools
that draw on real world field trials
with octopus energy customers and the
insights about real world behaviors that
we obtain from those trials
um we can run these field trials at
almost unprecedented scale so last
winter octopus energy ran a UK field
trial called the big dirty turndown and
that was with over 100 000 domestic
customers and that trial offered
customers different forms of incentive
to reduce their energy consumption or
move it away from periods when the grid
was particularly intense carbon
intensive
um examples are some of the models and
tools that we're currently developing
Faraday which is an API and a web-based
tool Which models energy consumption
profiles for different Target
populations under different conditions
so very important tool for the likes of
distribution system operators those who
are thinking about grid constraints grid
infrastructure trying to plan for the
future at crowdflex which uses field
trials to better understand and model
the amount of flexibility that could be
available to the power system at any
point in time from households changing
their energy consumption in response to
different external signals or incentives
and baselining which is work that we're
doing to understand how to more
accurately more accurate ways to
establish a baseline or a counterfactual
for a given customers energy consumption
in the absence of any external signals
and this is very important because that
Baseline and the ability to to measure a
alter or a difference could become very
important for things like the greenhouse
gas protocols development of scope 4 or
avoided emissions
all of these models and tools account
for adoption of low carbon Technologies
by households so Chris talked about the
the speed and the scale of some of these
things I think one of the things that's
most striking is that the speed and the
scale at which ordinary households will
need to adopt different Technologies
than they might have today so we're
particularly interested in things like
electric vehicles heat pumps solar home
batteries and we're interested in how we
can expect households to use these
Technologies in ways that are compatible
with their Lifestyles and we think this
is important because the future isn't
some abstract concept that will just
happen to us it's something that we can
actively create but we need to make sure
that we're actively creating it by
making decisions that are grounded in uh
that are that are not only grounded in
theory but are also rooted in what we
understand about people's real world
lives and in the fullness of time we
expect that more and more intelligent
automation will apply to how these
Technologies are used and how they
support The Wider power system but it's
important that in order for public
acceptance public support that's an
automation that really understands
people's Lifestyles
um maybe just to say finally the
decisions that we take now and in the
next decade will have very important
consequences for the cost and and the
shape of future infrastructure such as
where and how much transmission and
distribution networks we need to build
how markets should be allowed or
encouraged to develop and what that
means for different people's rights and
responsibilities or different
organizations rights and
responsibilities and that of course has
implications for very important matters
like equity and justice
and just very briefly how how does the
information you because it sounds like
you know this is clearly important
research these are necessary things to
know who is interested and who's using
it you know do you find it do you find
that sort of governments and policy
makers are most interested is it
businesses is it consumers themselves
like who where is all this feeding into
yeah I think it's a it's a great
question I think it's a mix of all of
those things so certainly uh
government's policy makers we talk to on
a very regular basis were involved in a
lot of different
um conversations on that front uh we do
publish our research openly so earlier
this year for instance we we published
actually a bespoke model we made which
was uh an agent based model where we ex
we simulate a different policy
interventions to to to look at which
combinations of interventions might meet
the UK government's Target for annual
heat pump installations we published
that report called hitting the Target
and the code behind it on GitHub so
that's openly available we try to do
this with a much of our work as possible
we find though that it's uh it's not
just governments it's not just policy
makers we have a lot of interest from
those responsible for planning uh where
additional grid might need to be built
um so certainly transmission Network
operators distribution system operators
others in industry and and maybe others
developing some of these these
technologies that I'm talking about as
well so um all of those along with just
other academics who may want to use some
of our tools for their own research
questions
well I'm sure you know the question of
transparency coming along like the speed
of change is very interesting because I
think it almost forces transparency
because then because everybody needs to
do everything all at once and you can't
afford a top-down structure okay let's
come to Jonathan then and um you know
Jonathan companies like Cummings have
in order you know this is not something
this a big transition like this doesn't
happen without corporations some
corporations being on board I guess the
ones that don't get on board just get
left left in the dust but um what are
you know specifically for Cummins and
the way you look at the world what are
your sustainability goals for 2030
yeah so it's a great question so um you
know we're in this what we call
Destination zero so we're heading
towards destination zero we realize that
our industry is completely changing it's
completely changing and evolving and and
we're managing through this transition
so we're really driving towards you know
the Net Zero you know as we aim for 2050
we've made those commitments for 2050.
but for 2030 you know we provide Power
Solutions and power system solutions to
customers that run businesses that
um that need to you know use Vehicles
use our applications use our industrial
uh Power to actually manage their
vehicle to manage their businesses to be
sustainable as well so they're meeting
their multiple girls so we have a number
of initiatives that we're driving and
heading towards the destination zero
reducing reducing the greenhouse gas
emissions from our products you know
driving our greenhouse gas reductions
from our products and reducing those
also you know um scope three greenhouse
gases from all our facilities
um our operations all of those were
driving reductions in those through 2030
to be at Net Zero by 2050 looking at our
sites and how we drive out the
operational expense of our sites but the
reality is most of our our carbon
emissions are from our products so a lot
of our Focus actually is on our products
because we make diesel engines you know
for over 100 years we've made diesel
engines natural gas engines and and
we're now driving towards developing
um zero carbon solutions that we can
actively roll out into the market to
start to shift that but also focusing on
how do we actually reduce the emissions
and the carbon from our products that
we're selling today because we're going
through this transition where we'll have
two paths one is which is my job is is
in innovating and bringing in new
technologies that are zero carbon like
fuel cells and batteries and other those
other low emission applications but also
taking out carbon from our existing
products so making our internal
combustion engine products more fuel
efficient and driving goals to reduce
efficient reduce the fuel used by those
products and and having a dual approach
to enable us to manage through this what
is going to be this sort of tough
transition as we go from here through to
2030
um where zero emission products are
going to take time to be economically
viable infrastructure needs to be put in
place Investments need to be made at a
really massive scale to make them viable
um we we're managing that on sort of two
fronts you know one is to bring in those
new technologies prove them out test
them get them into real Market get them
to real customers but then in parallel
really driving down the emissions from
our sites our facilities and our and our
products that are actually out there in
the field right now
well I'd just like to pick up on one
point there because actually one of the
things I think that's especially
interesting
um four companies like Cummins is that
you know there's all the there's all the
carbon burned if you're if you're you
know technology goes out into the world
but actually the business of generate
like building things Supply chains
factories you know the so what's called
embodied carbon of the object but
actually it's it's the entire system
it's like the internal system of the
company and is that a bit as big a
challenge for you as the technology
itself or is the is that relatively
straightforward you think to actually
have when you're producing things to use
systems that actually use this new
thinking as well I wouldn't say one is
harder or easier than the other they
both represent a very unique Challenge
and of course we have Global plants and
Facilities all around the world and so
it brings different opportunities to
enable to reduce our you know our carbon
our carbon footprint around the world I
give one example you know we've recently
installed solar in our facilities in
India you know solar in India is um you
know it's really low cost it's really
effective you get very high efficiency
from it if the sun shines a lot in India
so you can drive down there's different
programs you can do in different regions
to really drive down the carbon
footprint of our facilities
um your point about Supply chains is a
really good one because when we think
about carbon footprint as well we've got
to think about what we call Welter
Wheels you can't just think about the
carbon footprint of the vehicle or the
system or the facility you've got to
look at the entire from the well to the
wheel and how you think about carbon
reduction for products and and us on our
facilities but but a big challenge you
know if you looked at our carbon you
know like carbon footprint you know it
is hugely about our products you know
that is a big part of what of what we do
we produce a lot of internal combustion
engine products and and so a very heavy
Focus for us is on how we reduce and so
how we reduce the carbon footprint how
we improve the efficiency and and we've
got to make those products
um commercially viable because customers
who buy our products are running their
businesses so they're running their
businesses they they need those products
to be be yes sustainable but also
commercially viable available can be
supported with an infrastructure and so
they go through all those thoughts and
when they make those choices about the
products they buy and so our role is to
is to bring that technology to start to
make it viable and to work with
governments and and others to drive you
know the adoption of the of the
infrastructure that that makes those
products viable which will be the key to
you know decarbonizing you know a large
part of our products
awesome well well now we've we've met
you all we will broaden that discussion
a bit and I I wanted to actually start
on the time scales because so I am not a
big fan of this kind of 12 Years to save
the world language because I think it
makes it sound like you know you want to
tidy up the house before your relatives
come to visit next weekend maybe you
could do it today maybe you could do it
on Friday maybe you could do it three
minutes before they turn up and actually
that's not what we're facing we're
facing a situation where the sooner we
do things the better it all gets so it
does make a difference whether you do it
now or next year
um but Chris I'm interested in the you
know from your point of view but time
scales are helpful what what do we need
to do you know within 10 years within 30
years that kind of thing so Chris um
when it comes to between the time
between now and 2030. what are the as
far as you're concerned what are the
priorities here
it looked clearly clearly we've got to
accelerate the expansion of wind and
solar on electricity supplies so I'll
Focus first on the supply side wind and
cell is going to do the heavy lifting
during this decade without a doubt
um and we're going to need to expand
some demand side Technologies like
electric vehicles like household heating
like industrial efficiency uh because
you know that's going to make the task a
lot easier if we get the demand side
moving along as well
uh and with increasing wind and solar
we're going to have to make sure we have
the batteries and the uh firm other firm
generation sources that can can maintain
stability with these variable resources
but you know we can't just focus on 2030
because there's 2031 is the very year
after and there's a whole range of
technologies that we are counting on to
expand post 2030 and we have to work on
those this decade if they're going to
have a chance of meeting the task ahead
things like CO2 capture and storage
otherwise known as CCs is large
expectations for CCS mostly post 2030.
uh and and I think the other thing that
we've got to think hard about is
infrastructure like and you know
enabling infrastructure like
transmission and Distribution Systems as
we increase the electric vehicles and
electric uh Heating and households we're
gonna have to expand substantially the
distribution networks and we're going to
with with more and more winds wind and
solar because it is sort of more
dispersed across the landscape we're
going to need large investments in
transmission and these are hard
Investments to do right they take
they're long to permit they're long to
get communities behind
and when you think about 2030 it's eight
years away and so if we you know it it
can take you at least a decade to permit
wind and solar and the same will be true
for things like
um like CCS you know if we want to be if
we want to be building out CCs in in the
2030s we need to start the permitting
process now
um and so you know I I don't think
there's any stone you can leave unturned
this decade but what what is visible to
us what's coming out of the ground as
operating assets is going to be wind
solar batteries electric vehicles uh and
some transmission and that's going to
look like it's done all the work but but
we can't leave those other things behind
and you see a sort of frustration now in
you know so quite often certainly for
domestic
um solar for example but also in a lot
of you know there are there are supply
chain issues everyone's kind of going oh
oh okay we want some solar panels and
they can't buy them because the
factories aren't making enough the
material you know that the whole thing
hasn't scaled up enough do you see
just get you worried at all that there
might be this frustration that we have
this couple of years now where
everyone's all enthusiastic like okay
let's do this and then they kind of get
to oh well we can't you know I can't buy
it I can't get one I've got I mean
they're waiting you know I'm in a queue
for an electric car that's maybe six
months or something do you think we risk
kind of taking the edge off it a bit
because there's that we can't make use
of that initial Rush of enthusiasm just
because you know the system isn't quite
with us yet
look I I think supply chain constraints
are inevitable there's just so much to
do so quickly uh and one of my
frustrations is not whether we'll become
frustrated I'm frustrated that
governments don't see their role as a
kind of a master planner coordinator
supply chain constraints in a net zero
transition are inevitable and so we've
got to learn to uh coordinate and
sequence the expansion of Supply chains
the expansion of infrastructure and the
expansion of these assets it's it's it's
too easy for us to say all we need to do
is build wind and solar it's there's so
much more there's all of the
manufacturing facilities there's the
critical minerals you know the supply
chain is just a very complex thing and
it like the like the assets themselves
has its own long lead term and lead time
and permitting constraints
so yeah look I I think I think we are at
risk of not facing up to the complete
challenge not coordinating our response
and running out of steam and so you know
that's why I think it's vital that
governments really get Hands-On and get
involved in this
I just wanted to just sort of uh sort of
build on that point a little bit I think
the coordination of the supply chain is
a really really important point and
because the worst thing you could do of
some of the bad things you could do is
go too too slow in some areas too fast
another I use an example of if you don't
build out renewable energy fast enough
and keep increasing your production of
hydrogen as an example you know which is
you know fuel for for the future and how
we think about it in terms of
decarbonization but if you don't build
out your Renewables and keep making
hydrogen from fossil fuels that's a
really bad outcome right it's a really
bad outcome yes we'll have hydrogen and
be able to use it in fuel cells and
other things but it's a bad outcome
because you're making it from from a
fossil fuel so this whole sort of
sequencing of the supply chain I think
is just incredibly important as we think
through this this transition so I just
wanted to add that point you know great
thank you and Lucy I was interested in
your uh your perspective on the on the
eight years theme because what you were
talking about before was you know partly
at least partly social science research
you know how do people respond to things
because it's not just you know we all
like to think that we're logical actors
and that we do what we should rationally
do and of course that's complete
nonsense we don't at all almost never
um so what what do you see in the sort
of priorities for the next eight years
in terms of Shifting Minds as well as
spreadsheets yeah that's
um probably a few a few things to to say
there I mean I think um maybe building
on some of Chris's comments and when you
look at uh every sector needs to
decarbonize but when you look at those
sectors that are really really critical
uh you see transport and you see uh
heating ventilation and cooling of
buildings but when you unpack those
actually you see that the the biggest
contributions in terms of emissions
don't come from uh business and industry
but they come from residential
um uh in the heating uh ventilation
cooling uh sector and then for transport
you see that it comes not from Aviation
and shipping but actually it comes from
roads transport and when you unpack that
it comes from privately owned Vehicles
so
um what I'm saying here is that actually
it is individual households that will
need to make some big big shifts and
this really feeds to your point Helen
they're so mindset changes that need to
go on here people need to make decisions
to
um to change to to different uh and
newer Technologies now um we're in quite
a privileged position in some ways in
that these Technologies are not so new
that they don't exist yet these aren't
we aren't talking about things that need
to be invented they're already here
they're already with us I think um one
of the things that uh is is very
important here and uh I'm really pleased
to see some stuff come out in the
inflation reduction act in the in the US
to support this but is um means of
Finance
um that can help households to purchase
these Technologies some of them have
very high upfront costs
um so really thinking about
um ways that we can help households with
those costs um I talked earlier about
some of the work that we're doing on on
baselining household consumption and the
importance of having a kind of an
industry agreed counterfactual for
understanding the flexibility that a
household might provide through any low
carbon technologies that it owns
if we can do that and we can measure
that then we can quantify avoided
emissions and that could have a value in
the offset Market if we can find a way
to integrate that value to track it
right back into the financing of those
low carbon Technologies then we may have
some interesting new uh commercial
models that can open up so I think the
the financing particularly for
individual households is critical and
just also building on both Chris and
Jonathan's points they talked about
um a lot of discussion about supply
chain I also think it's important to
talk about the skills constraints here
um I talked about our hitting the target
piece of modeling our agent-based model
in which we simulated different
interventions to see which of those
might meet the government the UK
government's Target for 600 000 heat
pump installations per year by 2028. we
did find some scenarios in our modeling
in which we modeled the demand would be
sufficient to hit that Target but
actually it would be constrained in the
short to medium term by lack of trained
installers so we had some scenarios in
which we said between 2025 and 2027 we
will need another 30 000 trained heat
pump installers it sounds like a large
number it's not really when you put it
in the context of how many gas
registered uh boiler installers we have
in the UK which is about 120 000 so
we're really talking about potentially
retraining a quarter of that number by
2025 to 2027 but obviously
um you know we we need to be taking the
right decisions and doing the right
things now to retrain those people I
think there um is huge potential for
green jobs growth here but only if we
make the right decisions in the next
year or so
yeah I was just going to add to that our
estimate across the whole energy economy
for the US was a two to three-fold
increase in jobs across the energy
economy uh by 2050. that is a tremendous
challenge to find those people
especially now in a full employee fully
employed economy I mean I think people
is going to be a critical constraint
and of course it takes not only time to
retrain people but they need to have a
salary while they're retraining in order
you know in order to to live while
they're doing it okay let's let's we
could delve so deeply into all of these
things but let's move on I want to pick
up on something Lucy said about the
inflation reduction act which has these
enormous numbers attached to it you know
I think 738 billion dollars and it's
authorized 391 billion dollars of that
in in spending on NG and climate change
so potentially this sounds like a huge
lever now obviously it was also people
had bigger Ambitions for it and you know
it's obviously better that something
happened rather than nothing but it
wasn't all of the everything that some
people were hoping for so I'm interested
in your opinions on you know what are
the biggest how big a lever is this how
much is it going to shift and what
perhaps isn't going to be done by this
act but might need to be done by
something else
who's going to pick up on the uh the IRA
well maybe I'll start just from the
context of how we're thinking about it
in in comments firstly it's hugely
welcome you know when I think about
technology adoption
um in some of these markets that we
serve that are perhaps more challenging
to obey I think about three aspects of
this there's one which is do we have the
product offering is there the
infrastructure and how do you get to a a
cost I call it cost parity because those
are the three things that really matter
as you start to really try to accelerate
adoption rates so what the inflation
reduction act has has done
um and also you know the infrastructure
bill has really
um helped sort of push and incentivize
the building out of infrastructure the
adoption of clean and energy Vehicles
whether that's a battery EV electric
vehicle or a fuel cell electric vehicle
it also supports um you know clean fuel
options it gives sort of that Financial
impetus and drive to make the investment
to actually convert convert investments
into real projects and real execution
that can only help adoption rates
because otherwise constantly these these
zero emissions these zero carbon
Solutions are always playing that
challenge of how do they compete on cost
how do they compete in terms of
infrastructure and so I think government
help in this way is is hugely valuable I
think in terms of making those steps
forward but I'll let others come in
yeah I'm happy to have I go I I I think
uh likewise I mean there's incentives
across you know most of the critical
supply-side Technologies and the demand
side Technologies
um there's even uh incentives to
increase local manufacturing whether it
be EVS batteries solar panels Etc
um one of the weaknesses and it's an
unintended you know it's a well-meaning
policy that I think an unintended
weaknesses is as created supply chain
constraints so you know you only get the
full extent of benefits if you're buying
American-made employing union labor with
a certain level of Apprenticeship
Training programs and these are all
terrific like social policies on the
other hand they actually have the
ability to cause us to get off you know
offside with some of our other trading
partners who with whom we are well
aligned I mean we've got remember part
of this was about China proofing America
we want to make sure we don't Europe
proof and Australia proof and some of
the the Allies that we've had forever
um and so you know if I wanted to order
an electric vehicle in the US today I
would probably be waiting and get the
and get the incentive I would probably
be waiting for 18 months for my vehicle
um and and so you know I think I think
it will undoubtedly stimulate the uptake
of some of some of these Technologies
and it will it's very welcome as
Jonathan says I I just think we we've
got to be careful we don't lose the the
real power of what this could have been
uh because it slows us down around
conditionality
um I'd be interested to hear what Lucy
thinks
uh very quickly Lucy because we've got
so much more to talk about actually just
before that so we are not quite quite
time at audience question time yet but
um just to remind the audience that you
can be asking questions now there's a q
a tab that you can click on do put your
question in there tell us your name tell
us where you're from you can be doing
that now we will come to those questions
in just a couple of minutes Lucy if you
could be quick if you've got thoughts on
the infrastructure reduction inflation
reduction act we definitely don't want
an infrastructure reduction
if we want a polluting infrastructure
reduction act
um well I've got one quick question
before we get to questions but yes so
very quickly yeah sure well I suspect uh
both Chris and Jonathan are far more
familiar with the the detailed
provisions of the ACT but um what I will
say
um
um of course any anything of this nature
is very very welcome to see uh even if
it's not quite perfect in its execution
um very comprehensive I think from what
I've seen which is certainly um
reassuring
um I uh was particularly be pleased to
see some of the finance Provisions that
are in there particularly around
providing the finance to sufficiently
de-risk projects that might not
otherwise have been funded without that
finance and also to see although I'm not
familiar with the precise the finer
details of this um I think there was a
commitment to provide around three
billion dollars I think for uh to to
change the entire fleet of the U.S
Postal Service to EVS
um I think that could be very
interesting in terms of understanding
how uh large owned and operated fleets
um could play a role in the Future
Energy System
you know I love that example so I know
um many of our audience will be American
but just for your information in the UK
when I was a kid there were these little
vans that went around developing milk
and this is several decades ago now and
they were all electric and I love the
idea that it's kind of come around again
okay
um so just very briefly before we get to
audience questions now
um different type of question perhaps so
there are a lot of problems in the world
and um they all intersect you know it's
not just the case that we can fix energy
or we can fix transport and then we can
just not touch anything else you know
there's an opportunity here to connect
in with perhaps you know dealing with
geopolitical issues and things like
equality and how communities work
there's all these other things that you
know if you're going to make big changes
it seems like you might as well at least
try and uh do it in a good way for
everybody not just for your narrow
issues how do you see these these big
goals you know eight years to 2030 what
are the opportunities for
combining you know this big systems
thinking about energy and transport with
the the social issues and the political
issues that are happening right
alongside it
who's going to take that one tough
question
oh you're not shy go on look okay I'll
ever I'll ever first go
um look I think there is a real
opportunity to get some of the some of
the social justice issues right
um and I think um for for lower income
households
um some of these Support options we
would have in terms of procurement are
really worth making sure we get right
um I think where we cite assets you know
uh the sort of requirement for a much
more sensitive and deeper Community
engagement and ultimately when we think
about the scale that we're going to need
to go all the way to 2050 we're going to
have to start sharing more value around
these energy projects with local
communities you know in the past you
know I'm an ex-developer we used to
develop projects so as to we we would
negotiate with the community in order
not to be stopped there's so much
involved in Net Zero we have to have a
new approach which is having the
community right beside you right behind
you as partners and I think you know if
we can if we can get that instilled in
these early years of the transition it
will stand Us in really good speed
any other contributions on that yeah go
on well just real real briefly you know
obviously the very recent challenges
we've got in the energy Supply you know
and the cost of energy one of the things
that we really can't lose here is
um energy there's energy security but
there's also the sustainability and the
zero you know zero emission zero carbon
uh future we want to have we've got to
hold on to both of those and you know
getting to a point where we can drive to
lower and lower cost and more stable
energy costs in the future has has got
to be incredibly beneficial for
everybody but of course Energy prices
impact the lower income groups much more
and and so if we can use this as an
opportunity to build out a you know a
low carbon zero carbon future energy
sources that are much more predictable
it costs in the future that's got to be
something we've got to try and hang on
to so I'll just just add that commentary
yeah Lucy yeah yeah maybe just quickly
um I mean I I think there are real
opportunities here
um we we spend an awful lot of money
here in the UK
um on uh curtailing energy
um uh and uh issues around grid
constraints so actually I think there
are a lot of the concepts of things that
we're talking about here could actually
reduce the amount that we spend on those
things at the moment actually you look
at all of the forecast so that's just
only forecast to increase more in the
future
um ultimately these costs are socialized
onto every customer's bill
um so actually delivering some of the
concepts the things that we're talking
about could bring bills down for
everyone
um I think we're also seeing um have the
potential to see some very interesting
Community models um octopus energy
actually owns a couple of uh onshore
wind turbines uh in the UK we have
something called The Fan Club so you can
join final Club one or fan club 2
depending whether you live
geographically close to one of those two
turbines
um if you do then you get a lower rate
on your unit cost of energy when the
wind speed exceeds a certain amount
um so um you know I think that's very
interesting as well the other thing I
would say though is I think these these
issues of sort of justice and Equity are
very live issues and I think they're
ones that uh we will really need to to
address head-on as we start to see more
use of household level distributed
energy resources within the Future
Energy System
um at the moment we have uh markets and
mechanisms that enable utility scale
facilities to participate in power
markets um so for instance utility scale
battery storage facilities we could have
an equivalent uh by aggregating
households so they could provide a
similar uh similar services within the
the power system but we don't yet have
markets or protections or mechanisms
that really um
attempt to discuss or to think about
what the sort of Rights and
responsibilities would be in that kind
of market so how do we make sure that an
individual householder might be rewarded
or compensated in the same way as a
utility scale provider and how do we
similarly set out the other side of that
coin so what are their rights but also
what are their responsibilities if
they're going to be part of that system
I've seen some interesting work early
work come out from some academics in
Australia on this point a paper called I
think just Dr Bill of Rights and
responsibilities it is not a draft bill
it is a discussion paper to start a
debate and I think these sorts of topics
are are very important topics for the
next decade or so
okay right let's get to audience
questions audience just as a reminder
you there's a button somewhere that says
q a on it do find that and remember to
press send after you typed your question
I didn't say that for it's very
important that you press send okay so so
we're going to deal with a big group of
questions together which is that we have
had a lot of questions about individuals
and the cost of heating and this is
obviously very relevant especially in
the UK here at the moment but but it's
not just a UK issue no it's caused by
bigger Global factors but when it comes
to individuals and the cost of heating
and affording things like a heat pump or
insulation like the money's got to come
from somewhere and there's already a
cost of living crisis and you know you
can see the average person on the street
going well you know I think this is all
great but I can't afford you know I it's
not like I've got spare money sitting
around to to afford these big changes
how how do we what do we do about that
like what I mean it's it's very easy to
State the problem what what are the
solutions
for individuals specifically thinking
about here
yeah
I I mean I can really sort of repeat
what I said earlier which I think you
know grants and subsidies are important
to stimulate markets
um and to crowd in private Investments
do you risk private Investments
um uh but also I talked earlier about
um Finance models Finance mechanisms
um
I I know there are mortgage lenders here
in the UK who would love to find um
models that that work for them so that
um you know when people are maybe buying
a house or moving a house they can also
complete these measures they can make
their home more energy efficient they
can add these low carbon Technologies
um you know I I
um comforted in some ways that I know a
lot of discussions are going on on these
particular topics but I think that is
really the the Crux of the issue here is
is finding models of finance that are
going to work for the majority
and I guess one of the difficult things
here I mean you sort of you sort of did
both there which is very nice is that
these words like Finance kind of you
know it's a sort of word and the
ordinary person on the street is like
but what about my problem here you know
and actually I think those examples of
okay if you're gonna remortgage or you
know renew your mortgage or something
here is a thing that goes alongside that
like there's a language thing there
which actually leads into one of the
other uh questions we've had from
Twitter which is that a lot of the
metrics used to measure targets are hard
to understand like an Implement and so
the question is are we in danger of kind
of green washing climate change
Ambitions because you know there's some
number or there's some other number and
a company says they're doing something
and here's some number and you know
people haven't got the time to dig into
that and work out whether this number is
better than another number how what's
the risk here of companies just kind of
spouting measures that are hard to
understand and it just it all just sort
of Fades into nothingness because
everyone's spouting meaningless numbers
enormous I mean this is going on
everywhere every day
um from Big financial institutions to
you know energy companies
um you know I think
we just don't we just don't have a good
simple system around ESG reporting that
would force everyone to be transparent
and consistent and authentic
so whoever asks that question is it's a
critical question and there's been quite
a lot written about it recently so you
know I think a lot of people are focused
on it but it it's disturbing the way
it's happening right now
um and it's distracting
and Jonathan what do you see in this
from the you know from the Cummings
point of view yeah I mean I I don't
disagree there's an awful lot being
written about this I mean the way I
would say it's I think businesses have a
responsibility to be as specific as they
possibly can in terms of what it is
they're doing to actually reduce this so
get down to actual heart specific uh
metrics about
um their products their facilities and
and how they how are they actually what
are they actually doing you know how
much water are they really saving you
know what what is either the amount of
CO2 they're saving by
um installing
um you know Green energy product
facilities you know publishing really
clear data about the products that they
are that are selling and and how they
are manufactured and getting really
specific about you know the um scope 3
ghg targets which includes everything
the supply chain the whole aspect of the
value chain of how you make a product
and so with incomes we're trying trying
to do that and trying to make that
really clear through that sustainability
report every year to do that but but
it's like anything it's it's Clarity and
of course it's still a challenge about
how do I look at Cummins and then look
at another company in another company
and compare right how do I know and and
so I I tend to agree I I think you know
because it is a challenge to get that
consistency but businesses I think have
a real
um responsibility to be as clear as
possible about absolute targets and and
most importantly how they are actually
going about them is is what I would say
okay well let's pick up on that then so
since you're here as the representative
Cummins what what are you what projects
are you working on you know that you can
talk about tell tell us about the things
that are coming along the line that you
know you can be a little bit specific
about that you know are actually
happening yeah so some more broadly so
we could talk about product and
facilitation so
um in our products you know we are
actively
um working on and launching engine
products that are our next level of
engine products will be seven percent
more fuel economy um have a better fuel
economy than the products we launched
today so that is you know we're putting
that number out we're launching those
products and we're stating them so that
is tangible we can say as customers use
those products the impact of CO2
emissions from those products as a
result of a result of doing that
um we've also you know we are clear
we're you know putting in
um green energy
um energy sources into our plants I
talked earlier about that solar plan
that we put the solar facility that
we've put in in India which has been
able to reduce the amount of CO2 that we
produce through our operations
um you know we are working with um what
we call Cummins Waterworks where we are
actively focused on projects to increase
access of clean water to a larger number
of people then we would have up to 20
million people we want to get to a point
of providing clean waterfall so there's
projects like that that are really clear
and we State and we show and we we you
know we we put out there
um to to to demonstrate what we are
working on to to really meet our ESG
um goals and targets through 2013 and
you know beyond to 2050. so this is a
couple of examples
cool thank you
um okay so let's get so there's a
question here but I'd like to broaden it
out a bit more to the general question
of incentives and so this question's
from Colin Norris and the question is
what policies should governments
Implement to drive the market towards
net zero you know there's things like
carbon pricing Banning of Technology
mandating storage cap and trade and you
know we all know there's this big
discussion that's going on about how you
make these incentives work so when it
comes to carbon and decarbonization
specifically what what are your views on
which of these things what models
are actually going to work if
governments put them in place and is
there a risk that if you have different
governments make different decisions
about how they're going to incentivize
decarbonisation is that a risk all by
itself do we all need to agree
Lucy perhaps incentives for
decarbonization yeah
um so I'm sorry I've forgotten your name
who aren't asked the question but you
you listed a range of measures now uh in
my experience governments love to talk
about packages of measures but uh I
think there's something behind that in
that you're very unlikely to have just
one particular policy or one particular
measure that achieves the outcome you're
looking for so I think
um in answer to your original question I
think is probably all of the above plus
probably some additional uh stuff in
there as well
um I think from the kind of the the
energy point of view and particularly uh
you know we focus a lot on uh
residential customers the retail side of
things
um I think we need to see a really
significant retail Revolution so I've
talked a lot about households adopting
some of these low-carbon Technologies
but I I think also just um far more
Innovation on the retail side in terms
of things like rates and plans
um we have a number of different tariffs
in within the octopus Energy Group that
are
designed to help people use energy when
it's when it's cheaper so if you have an
electric vehicle for instance
um maybe to to intelligently charge that
vehicle at times when the grid is both
uh Greener and the electricity you're
using is is cheaper
um I think there's more work to be done
on just kind of price Discovery so what
does that actually look like what are
the types of incentives we can design
some of them will undoubtedly be related
to to price but actually some of them
might not
um you know there there may well be
customers who are willing to do things
differently
um just in the interests of the
environment
um so I think just having a better
picture of all of this and then thinking
about how we can build it into
particularly into retail Innovation it's
going to be really important and um the
availability and the sort of abundance
of data is going to be very important to
understand that
yeah and maybe yeah I think I'll go yeah
no I didn't want to talk about well I
was going to say I think the other piece
I'd say about legislation is is around
its consistency I think consistency and
building a framework and tough and
enforceable you know I I think that's
important you know that that companies
and businesses and others understand
what they have to achieve and where
they're moving to and have that level of
consistency and be able to build upon
that and have that enforceable and when
I say consistency it's also very
beneficial to have levels of consistency
globally as well you know as you think
about products that get shipped around
the world and and we're driving
consistent standards and that I think is
also important to help Drive Innovation
and and product development that that
helps
accelerate adoption of products you know
that enables us to start to build at
scale because once you can start to
develop products you know that meet
legislation that meet tough enforceable
legislation build them at scale once you
start building scale costs start coming
down adoption rates start going up and
you start to then you know build this
adoption rate which is you know has this
virtual circle of starting to then um
move things faster as you know as we
head towards adoption of of you know
zero carbon Solutions
well it really highlights what Lucy was
saying before about
um you know the decisions we make now
matter because if you set a standard
early everyone knows what it is and you
can all just get on with it whereas if
you have a sort of you know VHS betamax
debate for 10 years
exactly it's time consuming and you
can't afford the extra you know
but the other thing the resource goes
into that the thing I'd say though is I
think governments need to be setting um
you know legislation around
um what needs to be achieved but be more
technology agnostic you know and what I
mean by that is don't the government
shouldn't be there prescribing the
solution they should provide the
framework and what's required to meet
the to meet the requirements and the
goals and let industry business you know
innovate to come up with the right
Technology Solutions to meet those
requirements don't be much more
technology agnostic
because of course there may be
Technologies no one's thought of yet
that could do quite a lot of the heavens
exactly right right exactly so let
business do what business does well and
actually drive the economy through
Innovation by by setting really tough
enforceable targets but don't set them
to you know to exclude technologies that
perhaps we haven't thought of today or
perhaps aren't in favor today or
whatever that may be because Innovation
is happening everywhere in this space
um okay so there's a question here from
Twitter and I think this is a sort of
background worry so I'm dropping it in
because it's not directly relevant to
all of the discussion we've had but I
think it's something that is on people's
minds so I think we should address it
um it's Anonymous but it says what can
be done about countries which don't put
significant effort into achieving these
goals and I think really the question is
here
if we accept that this is a global
effort but different Global players have
different capacity or will to act how do
we kind of you know how do we balance
this out do we should we all just do the
most we can do and not worry too much
about everyone else or do we need to you
know how do we do this and find it fair
in the right kind of way because
obviously developing countries for
example are much less able to develop
Technologies and the problem wasn't
theirs in the first place so how do we
think about these different Global
players
all making their Fair contribution but
then working out what fair means
Lucy here yeah I mean I it's a it's a
great question I I think really I mean
this this comes this is all this is what
cop is all about right so it's getting
all of these countries around the table
and they every country has is in a
different position has different
resources available has different
motivations
um every country feels the impact of the
effects of climate change differently
um so I think really uh it is about
getting everyone around the table and um
trying to find those consensus points um
and uh
this is certainly not easy nothing to do
with International diplomacy is is ever
easy but I think we can look at things
like the Paris agreement and like the
Glasgow agreement and say that actually
this process
has been effective historically and uh
it should continue to be the vehicle
through which uh we do
um really sort of thrash out these
differences and maybe thrash out these
uh different levels of inclination to
act and to make sure that we are coming
to agreements internationally
well I think that's a great place to
finish cop is coming up in just a few
days now so I hope you know hopefully
this will be discussed much more in in
the media and outside and so because we
are out of time we're going to have to
finish so um I think we lost Chris
towards the end there which is a great
shame but in his absence we will thank
Chris as well as Lucy and Jonathan uh
thank you to everyone who listened in or
who participated uh to intelligence
squad for organizing this to Cummins for
being part of that organization and
sponsoring it
um and of course the next event is
coming up in a couple of weeks and that
will work for there we will be
discussing the next bit along which is
between 2030 and 2050 to to examine what
happens when we're sort of really
getting into the stride of this uh
getting into our stride uh and and what
we need to prepare for that so if you'd
like to attend that one do visit
intelligencequared.com uh you can sign
up to their newsletter to make sure you
get notifications or about it or you can
just register for the next event and for
more information about Cummins you can
just visit cummins.com and that's it for
today so I hope you've all we've left
you all with some food for thought for
your afternoon or your morning whatever
comes next
um so thank you very much everyone and
from us here at Intelligence Squared
goodbye